Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Ever find yourself shouting at your kids only to feel guilt afterwards? You are not alone.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你是否曾发现自己对孩子大吼大叫，事后却感到内疚？你并不孤单。
Shouting is often our go-to response when we feel overwhelmed or when we feel like we're not being listened to, but it doesn't need to be. In today's episode, I am chatting with Dr. Jade Redfern, clinical psychologist and parenting coach. We are breaking down why we shout, the hidden functions behind our outbursts, and most importantly, how to regulate your emotions so you can calmly guide your child through theirs. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along. I am Dr. Marianne and I'm a clinical psychologist. I am a human first and a psychologist second and interestingly those are the exact orders that I got my qualifications in but after becoming a
当我们感到不知所措或觉得不被倾听时，大吼大叫往往是我们下意识的反应，但其实不必如此。在今天的节目中，我邀请了临床心理学家兼育儿教练Jade Redfern博士。我们将剖析我们为何会大吼大叫，这些爆发行为背后的隐藏功能，以及最重要的一点：如何调节情绪，从而冷静地引导孩子处理他们的情绪。希望这对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听。我是Marianne博士，一名临床心理学家。我首先是一个人，其次才是心理学家，有趣的是，我获得这些资格的顺序也正是如此。但在成为一名
qualified psychologist I then became a parent and I know that for many of us we might find ourselves working in services or suddenly becoming a parent ourselves and thinking, oh, I'm woefully ill-equipped. One of the hot topics in parenting can be when it feels like you are shouting more than you would like to. And there's such important reasons behind that. Let's dive into today's episode, which is just complete soul food and so incredibly useful. Hope you will love it. I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Dr. Jade Redfern. Hi, Jade. Hi, Marianne. Thanks for having me.
合格的心理学家后，我成为了母亲。我知道，我们许多人在工作中或自己为人父母后，会突然觉得：“天哪，我完全没有准备好。”育儿中最热门的话题之一，就是当你发现自己吼孩子的次数比预想的要多时。这背后有非常重要的原因。让我们进入今天的节目，这绝对是心灵的食粮，而且非常实用。希望你会喜欢。我想欢迎今天的嘉宾，Jade Redfern博士。你好，Jade。你好，Marianne。谢谢你邀请我。
Thanks so much for coming on. We have been regulars in each other's inboxes over the years, but it's really lovely to have you on the podcast. Yeah, absolutely. It's always lovely to have the support online, but yeah, lovely to be here. I've been a fan of your podcast, so it's always lovely to have the support online but yeah lovely to be here i've been a fan of your podcast so it's good to be here oh that's really kind of you today and i'm such a fan of your work jade i find you to be calm in the storm of parenting chaos that's how it feels it's funny because we've had this conversation before being the calm and I think sometimes yeah well we'll unpick it today but there's so much that we can say about that yeah so the people
非常感谢你能来。多年来我们一直在彼此的收件箱里互动，但能在播客中邀请到你真的太棒了。是的，绝对是。能在网上得到支持总是很棒，但能来到这里真的很好。我一直是你的播客粉丝，所以能来到这里感觉真好。哦，你太客气了。Jade，我非常欣赏你的工作，在育儿的混乱风暴中，你总能给人一种冷静的感觉，感觉就是这样。这很有趣，因为我们之前讨论过保持冷静的话题，我想有时候——是的，我们今天会深入探讨——关于这一点我们有很多话要说。是的，所以对于那些
tuning in what are they gonna get by listening to or watching this episode what's our hope for today Jade I think really to think I mean it's a couple of things I guess there might be you know some listeners who are parents themselves. So I hope for them that they can kind of walk away from this episode kind of feeling a little calmer themselves, but also feeling like, I don't know, I think there's just so much guilt in parenting around, we're questioning whether we're doing it right. Am I messing my kids up? And so I think anybody who faithfully listens to my work or works with me doesn't feel that. And that we don't have to be a calm parent all of the time. There's lots of things we can do that will help us. But I think also, as we were chatting earlier, for anyone who isn't a parent, you know, understanding when
正在收听或观看本期节目的朋友，你们能从中获得什么？Jade，我们今天有什么期待？我想，真的可以从几个方面来思考。我想可能有一些听众本身就是父母。所以我希望他们听完这期节目后，能感到内心平静一些，同时也觉得——我不知道，我觉得育儿中存在太多的内疚感，我们总是质疑自己是否做得对。我是不是把孩子搞砸了？所以我认为，任何忠实听我节目或与我合作的人都不会有这种感觉。我们不必时刻做一个冷静的父母。有很多方法可以帮助我们。但我也认为，正如我们之前聊到的，对于那些还不是父母的人来说，
you're working with parents, what might be going on for them? You know, yes, they might be bringing their child to see you in clinical, but we also want to kind of bear in mind what might be going on for the parent. How can we support the parent as well? Yeah, and it's so important, isn't it, that we think about families holistically. And it actually starts from before a baby's born, sometimes even before a baby's conceived. How have people planned to become parents? How have they chatted with anyone around them about how they might plan to parent, how they might plan to create safe boundaries and safe discipline and to hopefully have a relationship that thrives. But I know that if people are watching this and thinking about the
当你与父母一起工作时，了解他们身上可能发生了什么？是的，他们可能会带孩子来看临床医生，但我们也需要考虑到父母身上可能正在发生什么。我们该如何支持父母呢？是的，从整体角度考虑家庭是非常重要的，不是吗？这甚至在孩子出生前就开始了，有时甚至在孩子受孕前就开始了。人们是如何计划成为父母的？他们是否与周围的人讨论过他们打算如何育儿，如何建立安全的界限和纪律，以及如何建立一段蓬勃发展的关系。但我知道，如果人们在看这期节目并思考
guilt and the shame, I know from working with psychologists and being one myself and people working in social care probably feel similarly, that you have that normal parent guilt and shame, but you also have the, oh, I'm a psychologist or I'm a social worker or I work in social care. I should know what I'm doing. I should be finding this easier. Yeah. So being a psychologist or working in social care or just understanding, you know, we have that kind of awareness, the impact that, you know, the early years on childhood or the way that we respond to our children, we have that awareness that it can have a big impact on our children's lives. And so then we can sometimes use that as a kind of pressure on ourselves that, you know, from our training, oh, I should know,
内疚和羞耻感，我从与心理学家的合作中，以及我自己作为心理学家的经历中知道，社会工作者可能也有类似的感觉，那就是你会有正常的育儿内疚和羞耻感，但你还会有一种“哦，我是心理学家，或者我是社会工作者，或者我在社会福利部门工作，我应该知道自己在做什么，我应该觉得这更容易才对”的想法。是的。所以作为一名心理学家，或者在社会福利部门工作，或者仅仅是理解——我们有那种意识，即童年早期或我们回应孩子的方式会产生影响，我们意识到这会对孩子的生活产生重大影响。因此，我们有时会把这种意识当作一种压力，认为根据我们的训练，“哦，我应该知道
you know, how I should be doing this. And in fact, for me, before I became a parent, you know, I'd worked in child and adolescent mental health. I'd worked with looked after children, trauma. So a lot of my work was with parents. I'd done a lot of training on parenting. But then when I became a parent and the anxiety that I felt and the, you know, my nervous system just felt like it was lit on fire and was never off, you know, just on kind of high alert. And I was really struggling. And I had this double layer of, I was struggling because it was hard. I was finding it hard because it is hard. And then I had the extra layer of guilt or that I've been supporting parents for years and now I feel like I don't know what I'm doing and so for me I think yes as professionals we could sometimes put that extra layer of guilt on ourselves particularly if
我该怎么做”。事实上，对我来说，在成为母亲之前，我曾在儿童和青少年心理健康领域工作。我曾与受照顾儿童、创伤儿童一起工作。所以我大部分的工作都是与父母打交道。我接受过很多关于育儿的培训。但当我成为母亲后，我感到的焦虑，以及我的神经系统感觉就像着了火一样，从未停歇，一直处于高度戒备状态。我当时真的很挣扎。我有一种双重压力：我挣扎是因为这确实很难，我发现这很难是因为它本来就很难。然后我还有额外的内疚感，因为我多年来一直在支持父母，而现在我觉得自己不知道自己在做什么。所以对我来说，我认为是的，作为专业人士，我们有时会给自己施加额外的内疚感，特别是如果你
you work with children and adolescents because you're thinking well hang on a minute I'm helping other families you know in my day job and then I go home and I'm struggling with my own and so we put a lot of pressure on ourselves. Yeah we we absolutely do. And, you know, if anyone is not yet a parent or doesn't ever want to become a parent, that's okay too. But wants to actually support families to parent more effectively, like it's okay that you're not a parent or you're not a parent yet. And I think one of the important questions is to kind of work out how it is for that person. You know, empathy can be important, but you don't always need to have been hit by a bus to know that it hurts. And so it's just trying to understand how it is for that person and what that means to them. Sometimes knowing
与儿童和青少年一起工作，因为你会想：“等等，我在日常工作中帮助其他家庭，然后我回家后却在为自己的家庭挣扎。”所以我们给自己施加了很大的压力。是的，我们确实如此。而且，如果有人还不是父母，或者永远不想成为父母，那也没关系。但如果你想真正支持家庭更有效地育儿，那么你不是父母或者还没成为父母也没关系。我认为一个重要的问题是弄清楚这对那个人来说是怎样的。同理心很重要，但你不需要被车撞过才知道那很痛。所以这只是试图理解那个人当下的感受以及这对他们意味着什么。有时了解
a little bit more about what came before for them and what their experience of being parenting was can kind of help you do your job better. Yeah, absolutely. I think it's having that understanding that if, you know, a child is coming to you or, you know, it's more than just the child that's coming to you. When you're working with a parent, you know, there may be a load of preconceived ideas about what they're hoping for. Maybe they're hoping for a diagnosis in their child because for many reasons, you know, diagnoses, yes, they can be helpful, but also sometimes parents are looking, the deeper layer can be that they're sometimes looking for it to be, please tell me this isn't something that I've done wrong. So it's just understanding that, you know, there are just
他们之前的经历以及他们被抚养的经历，可以帮助你更好地完成工作。是的，绝对是。我认为要有这种理解，即如果一个孩子来找你，或者说，来找你的不仅仅是孩子。当你与父母一起工作时，可能有一堆关于他们期望什么的先入为主的想法。也许他们希望孩子得到诊断，因为出于多种原因，诊断确实有帮助，但有时父母在寻找——更深层的原因可能是他们有时希望得到这样的答案：“请告诉我这不是我做错了什么。”所以这只是理解，
deeper layers to the ones that might be being presented to you. And actually sometimes when we suggest, oh, I think it'd be really good to have a session just with you. Some people might respond really well to that. Other people might be like me me? Why me? What have I done wrong? And so actually just being really clear that actually, you know, being a parent is hard and that's okay. And so actually you having a space where you feel you can safely kind of share what your experiences are like and how things are for you and what's going on for you is really, really helpful for me understanding you as a whole family. This isn't just about me understanding your child. I really want to understand you. And it's just taking that slightly different angle because you're aware that a parent is going to
除了你所看到的表象之外，还有更深层的原因。实际上，有时当我们建议“我觉得只和你进行一次会谈会很好”时，有些人可能会反应很好。而另一些人可能会想：“我？为什么是我？我做错了什么？”所以，明确地表达“为人父母确实很难，这没关系”是非常重要的。所以，你拥有一个可以安全分享你的经历、你的感受以及你身上发生了什么的场所，这对我从整体上理解你的家庭非常有帮助。这不仅仅是我理解你的孩子，我真的想理解你。这只是采取了一个稍微不同的角度，因为你意识到父母会
come with their own feelings of anxiety am I going to be judged am I going to be seen as the parent that's failing you know and particularly if there's social care involved there's so much stigma involved in that around is there something you know that I've done wrong and so when I work with parents very much speaking to some of the challenges that they might be having have have probably actually been there for many generations before them, you know, and that they are carrying, you know, many stories, many experiences, many challenges predate even their existence. And I think that can be hard, but comforting sometimes to hear. Yeah, absolutely. And we're just, you know, really aiming to de-shame this process. You know, none of us were born experts in parenting, you know, and it's something that we can't expect ourselves to be an expert in something
带着他们自己的焦虑而来：“我会受到评判吗？我会不会被视为一个失败的父母？”特别是如果涉及社会福利部门，周围会有很多耻辱感，关于“是不是我做错了什么”。所以当我与父母一起工作时，我非常关注他们可能面临的一些挑战，这些挑战可能在他们之前的几代人中就已经存在了，他们背负着许多故事、许多经历、许多挑战，甚至在他们出生之前就存在了。我认为这可能很难，但有时听到这些会让人感到安慰。是的，绝对是。我们真的旨在消除这个过程中的羞耻感。我们没有人天生就是育儿专家，这是我们不能期望自己成为专家的事情，因为
we've never done before. We do need to allow ourselves to grow. And, you know, that starts right with working out how you work out how a child is hungry and whether they're tired, you know, when they need their nappy changed when you know how to change a nappy like it's a normal there's so much to learn isn't there let alone how to begin to work out to feed that child once you work out they are hungry yeah absolutely and it's funny because I often think like if there was any other job we went into like imagine if you went into the job of a psychologist or a mental health worker and it was just like, here you go, here's your first case. And they can't do anything for themselves.
我们以前从未做过。我们需要允许自己成长。这从弄清楚如何判断孩子是否饿了、是否累了开始，比如当他们需要换尿布时，你知道如何换尿布——这很正常，有很多东西要学，更不用说当你弄清楚孩子饿了之后，如何开始喂养他们了。是的，绝对是。这很有趣，因为我经常想，如果我们从事任何其他工作——想象一下，如果你从事心理学家或心理健康工作者的工作，而对方只是说：“给你，这是你的第一个案例。”而且他们什么都不能自己做。
You know, you'd be like, oh, by the way, the manager's off sick. There's no supervisor. There's no rule book. There's no like, you know, just anyway, I'll check in in a couple of weeks, see how you're doing. And, you know, you'd be lost. And I think yet there's this expectation that society have, that we have, that it's just a job that especially for my whole motherhood it's just the most wonderful natural thing and actually for many of us it isn't and I think what I didn't even appreciate before becoming a mum was just how much my own stuff regardless of whether you feel you've got
你会想：“哦，顺便说一下，经理请病假了。没有主管。没有规则手册。没有……总之，我几周后再来看看你做得怎么样。”你会感到迷茫。但我认为，社会对我们有一种期望，即这只是一份工作，尤其是对于我的整个母亲生涯来说，这只是最美妙、最自然的事情。但实际上，对我们许多人来说并非如此。我认为我在成为母亲之前甚至没有意识到，我自己的那些东西——无论你是否觉得你的历史中有创伤，无论你是否觉得——对我来说，它激活了我成为母亲之前甚至不知道存在的某些部分，这真的让我很震惊。然后我还有另一层压力，那就是我对自己感到震惊，因为我想，同样，作为一名在创伤领域工作了20年的心理学家，这其实并不那么令人震惊。这在某种程度上是有道理的。但这是拥有那种生活经验的结果。我认为只要意识到，我们所有人内心都住着一个孩子，有时，我内心深处，她想跺脚、尖叫并要求吃冰淇淋，或者类似的事情。但我们的孩子会激活这些，当我们的孩子不听话时，
trauma in your history or not whether you feel like you know for me like it activated parts I didn't even know existed before I became a mum, you know, and so that really shocked me. And then I had this other layer that it shocked me that it shocked me because I thought, again, there's that I should, as a psychologist that's worked in trauma for 20 years, this actually isn't that shocking. It kind of makes sense. But it was having that kind of lived experience. And I think just being aware that, you know, there's still a child that lives on in all of us, you know, that sometimes, you know, inside of me, you know, she wants to stomp and scream and demand ice cream, I don't know, or something like that. But that, you know, our kids are going to activate, you know, when our kids don't listen,
因为孩子们会沉浸在他们正在做的事情中，他们不想做我们想让他们做的事情。我们内心可能会有一部分被此强烈激活，觉得我们的声音不重要，觉得我们很累、精疲力竭，我们想做……我们内心可能会有一部分被此强烈激活，觉得我们的声音不重要，觉得我们很累、精疲力竭，我希望能够只问一次，你就去做那件事。当然，这很有道理。从孩子的角度来看，他们只是孩子，他们沉浸在自己正在做的事情中。在与父母一起工作并帮助父母时，需要进行这种双重过程，因为我们必须明白，这是两个独立的个体，他们可能会与彼此纠缠在一起。所以，这也是为什么当我与父母一起工作时，他们说：“但我帮助其他父母和孩子，为什么我在自己的孩子身上却觉得这么难？”
because kids, you know, get engrossed in what they're doing, and they don't want to do the thing that we want to do. And we can have a part of ourselves that gets really activated by that, that our voice doesn't matter, that, you know, we're tired and exhausted, and we want to do. And we can have a part of ourselves that gets really activated by that, that our voice doesn't matter, that we're tired and exhausted and I want to be able to ask once and you just do the thing. And of course that makes sense. And from a child perspective, they're just being kids and they're engrossed in the thing that they're doing. And it's having that kind of dual process go on when working with parents and helping parents, because we've got to understand that these are two separate human beings that can get very enmeshed with one another. And so again, it's the reason why when I work with parents where they say, but I help other parents and children. So why am I finding it so hard with my own kids?
因为那是你自己的孩子，因为我们与他们纠缠得太深了。你在自己的孩子身上看到了自己的影子。这可能会非常触发情绪。但是，期望自己成为这方面的专家……当人们说我们是育儿专家时，我有时会感到不舒服。事实上，最近有人对我说：“哦，让我们看看……”然后我想，我的二儿子当时正在发脾气，正如他们常做的那样，我的朋友轻声对我说：“哦，让我们看看专家怎么处理。”我心想：“哦，请不要这样。”因为我也在经历一个普通母亲的时刻，心想：“好吧，我在公共场合。我的孩子正在发脾气。”
Because they're your own kids, because we get quite enmeshed with them. And you see parts of yourself in your own children. And that can be very triggering. But yeah, expecting ourselves to be an expert in this. And I sometimes feel uncomfortable when people kind of say we're being a parenting expert and in fact recently someone said to me oh let's watch and then I think my middle child he was having a bit of a tantrum as they do and and my friend sort of quietly said to me oh let's watch the expert play over thinking oh please don't because you know I was also having a human mom moment of like, okay, I'm in public. My child is having a tantrum.
我们可以知道该如何回应。但我现在有三个孩子，我是四个孩子中的一个，我丈夫来自一个大家庭。所以我们经常谈论你如何开始了解你的孩子，这需要时间，因为我把育儿看作一种关系，对吧？所以你在了解你的孩子，他们如何回应和反应，他们喜欢什么，不喜欢什么，以及你如何与他们互动。然后你有了另一个孩子，你心想：“哦，是的，这次我会做得更好。这次我知道我在做什么。”然后他们的反应和你第一个孩子不一样，他们需要稍微不同的方法。等等，
We can know how we could respond. But also, I now have three kids and I'm one of four and my husband's from a big family. So we often talk about how you might start to get to know your child and it takes time because I like parenting as a relationship, right? So you're getting to know your child, how they respond and react and react what they like what they don't and how you react with them and then you have another child you think oh yeah i'm going to be better this time you're gonna be better this i know what i'm doing this time and then they don't respond in the same way as your first child and they need a slightly different approach you know hang on a minute
到了第三个孩子，我肯定掌握了吧？不，我仍然在寻找新的方式来应对和回应我的孩子们。所以我认为我们一直在学习。这太真实了，Jade。说实话，我为第一个孩子带来的育儿经验是，他似乎真的很喜欢母乳，所以他吃得很多。无论他需要什么——饿了、累了、冷了、犹豫不决、长牙——他都很乐意喝奶。而且他喜欢唱歌。他喜欢我为他唱歌。这是我的两个常用策略，还有就是装傻，把他放在膝盖上颠啊颠的，唱着
so by the third child surely i've got this down and no i'm still finding you know new ways of like having to kind of react and respond to my children so I think we're always learning that is so true Jade and really what I brought to the parenting game for my first baby was he seemed to really like breast milk so he fed a lot and anything he needed hungry tired cold indecisive teething he was happy to have milk. And he loved singing. He loved it when I sung with him. And they were my two go-to strategies and kind of being silly and kind of bouncing him on my knee and stuff with, you know,
《Grand Old Duke of York》。然后我的第二个孩子出生了，我想：“我是一个相当不错的父母。这会没事的。我们将有两个这样可爱的男孩，一直都非常高兴和快乐。”结果第二个孩子出生了，他只在恰当的时候才想吃奶。否则就是大声尖叫，而且他不喜欢我唱歌。我会尖叫得更多。他不喜欢婴儿按摩，不喜欢赤身裸体。我心想：“哦，我所有的资源都用光了，我不知道该怎么办，完全没头绪，我该怎么办？”是的，绝对是。所以我想，这是为了了解这些只是拥有天生气质的独立个体。有些孩子，他们天生就拥有
the grand old Duke of York. And then my second one came along and I thought, I'm quite a good pair. This is going to be all right. We're going to have two of these wonderful boys, you know, just really, really delighted and happy all the time. And the second one came along and he only wanted to feed right at the right moment. Otherwise it was lots of screaming and he didn't like it when I sang. I would scream more. He didn't like baby massage, didn't like being naked. And I like oh I'm all I'm all out of resources I do not know what to do here like clueless where do I go with this yeah absolutely and and so I guess it's getting to know that these are just separate beings with temperaments that they're born with you know and some of our kids you know they are born you know with a more highly
更高度敏感的神经系统，容忍度更低。我的意思是，幼儿通常容忍度本来就低，但对于我们那些情感丰富的孩子，有些孩子对情绪被认可的反应很好。而另一些孩子，你认可他们的情绪，反而让情况变得更糟。这几乎就像是，我认为因为我们有些孩子对世界太敏感了，而且是在错误的时间。就像你说的，必须在特定的时间以特定的方式。你最终可能会觉得你做错了，但实际上，如果我们能把叙事改变为：“我如何能在这个时刻带来富有同情心的好奇心？”比如：“啊，好吧，那不太管用，那真有趣。”这在当下可能非常困难，我认为这需要
sensitive nervous system with a shorter window of tolerance. I mean, kids, young kids in general have short windows of tolerances anyway, but you know, in our deeply feeling kids, some kids respond really well to having their emotions validated. Other kids, you know, you validate their emotion and it seems to make it worse. It's almost like, I think because some of our kids are so porous to the world and it's at the wrong moment. Like you say, it's got to be at the specific moment in a specific way. And you could end up feeling like you're getting it wrong but actually if we can change that narrative to like how can i bring compassionate curiosity to this moment like ah okay so that doesn't quite that didn't quite work like isn't that interesting and that can be so hard in the moment i think it takes
大量的练习。我的意思是，我们谈论了很多关于同情心的话题，对他人产生同情心比对自己产生同情心要容易得多，对吧？但只要给自己许可去对正在发生的事情感到好奇，而不是陷入“我因为孩子心烦意乱或情绪化而把事情搞得一团糟”的故事中。实际上，孩子们就是巨大的情绪球，我经常说，有时没有足够大的容器来容纳其中的一部分。这确实很难。我记得我的儿子，我的二儿子在学前班时走路去学校，那大概是六七个月前的事了，他对我说：“我希望我有两个妈妈。”我意识到我内心有一部分感觉像是“噢，
a lot of practice i mean we talk a lot don't we about compassion and it's much easier to have compassion for others than it is for ourselves right but just giving ourselves permission to to be curious about what's going on instead of having that story that I'm getting this so horribly wrong because my child is upset or I don't know being emotional but actually kids are big balls of emotion and I often say you know there's there's no tank big enough sometimes you know to kind of contain some of it it's it is really hard and you know I remember my my son my middle child walking to school when it was preschool so it was probably about I don't know six seven months ago and he said to me I wish I wish I had two mummies and I recognized there was a part within me that was like oof
好痛”，因为那部分感觉到了：“我不够好。”但通过我所做的一些工作，有帮助的是实际上去想：“多么睿智的话啊。”事实上，我能够以一种方式回应：“我也希望有两个妈妈。那不是太棒了吗？”实际上我理解了，他只是想要我更多的时间。这并不意味着我
ouch because that part was sensing this, I'm not enough. But through some of the work that I've done, what helps is to actually go, what a wise thing to say. And actually, I was able to respond in a way that was, I wish there were two mummies too. Wouldn't that be amazing? And actually understood it that actually he just wants more of me. That doesn't mean I'm
不够好，只是我没有足够的时间。他能表达出来真是太棒了。这为你对自己和在那些时刻如何回应的感觉带来了完全不同的色彩。确实如此。而且我认为我看着我的孩子们，看着周围所有爱他们、想宠爱他们的人。我们不能进入一种关系，觉得如果他们想跑向祖父母、阿姨、叔叔甚至朋友，那就会对我们产生负面影响。因为事实并非如此，我们的孩子应该有充足的能力去爱和被爱。这并没有削弱我们作为父母的角色。我们必须摆脱自己的自负。关于“应该”这个词，我只有在父亲去世后，在小儿子18个月大时，才真正发现了同情心，
not enough there just isn't enough of me and isn't that wonderful that he can articulate that and then that brings a very different kind of flavor to how you feel about yourself and how you can respond in those moments it really does and you know I think I look at my children and I look around at all the people that love them and just want to adore them. We can't be kind of entering into a relationship where we're feeling like if they want to run to their grandparent or their aunt or their uncle or even a friend, that that reflects badly on us. Because it's not, you know, our children should have abundant capacity to love and be loved. And that doesn't diminish our role as a parent. And we've got to get out of the way of our own ego. And I think in terms of the shoulds, I only really discovered compassion,
自我同情和更广泛的同情。大概在他20个月大时发现的。我希望我能早点发现，因为我会少走弯路。我会寻求更多的帮助。我会知道我不必独自完成所有这些，在这一点上得到支持是可以的。这并不能说明我作为父母的任何问题，只会说明我会拥有更好的资源，我的容忍度会更高。我们需要确保在寻求帮助时做出安全的选择。但我相当确定我周围的人已经是安全的了。为什么我不能给自己
self-compassion and compassion more generally after my dad had died when my youngest was 18 months old. Probably discovered it around 20 months of his age. I wish I'd discovered it sooner because I would have got in my own way less. I would have asked for more help. I would have known that I don't need to do all of this alone and it's okay to be supported in that. And that doesn't say anything about me as a parent other than that I would have been better resourced and my window of tolerance would have been bigger. You know, we need to make sure we're making safe choices about who we're asking to help. But I was fairly certain the people around me were already safe. Why couldn't I give myself
许可去接受或寻求那种帮助，即使只是洗碗或推着婴儿在街区走走，让我能洗个澡？有时候我好几天、好几周都没洗澡，几周没洗头，就像纯粹用干洗喷雾。我值得比那更好的待遇。是的，绝对是。我认为当我们思考我们想给孩子什么礼物时，我们真的没有比爱孩子更爱的东西了。所以我们真的想给他们最好的，但有时我们给予得太多，放弃了太多的自我，让自己处于空转状态。实际上，我可以想到过去我与年轻人一起工作的时候，或者我有时建议：“我想知道是否……”我以协作的方式与家庭分享了这一点，但我不知道，你对孩子怎么看？“你觉得如果妈妈有一些会谈，或者妈妈有一个空间，或者她有一个可以倾诉的人，她可以带走她的一些感受，就像你有地方可以分享你的感受一样，会怎么样？”通常孩子们会像这样用力点头，不是因为他们……这从来没有让人觉得是因为你很高兴，但实际上，他们意识到父母也需要那种支持。我认为实际上我们的孩子——我经常说，孩子们不会做我们说的，他们会做我们做的。他们内化了我们照顾自己的方式。所以当我们和孩子在一起时，尤其是幼儿，他们需要照顾，他们要求很高，他们
permission to accept or ask for that help, even if it's just washing up or walking the baby around the block so I can have a shower? Like, sometimes I didn't have a shower for like days, days, days, weeks, hadn't washed my hair for weeks, like just pure Batiste. Like I deserved more than that. Yeah, absolutely. And I think when we think about, you know, what we want to give, gift, give to our children, you know, there's nothing really more that we don't love more than our children really. And so we want the best for them we really do but so much so that sometimes we give give up so much of ourselves and kind of leave ourselves you know running on empty when actually and I can think of times when I've been working with young people in the past or and I've sometimes suggested oh I'm wondering if and I've kind of you
确实需要很多关注，这确实很难。但同样，他们一直在向我们学习。如果我们从不给予自己，或者从不设定界限说：“我一会儿就来陪你，我只是去喝杯水，因为我渴了。”我们正在教他们很多关于不仅是他们的需求现在很重要，而且当他们长大后他们的需求也很重要，因为我们正在以身作则。这有时会让人觉得很难，但实际上，如果我们不注入，就无法倾倒。是的，非常有力的观点。我知道我们之前谈过，你说有时候当你的孩子对你说：
know shared it kind of collaboratively with the family but I'm wondering if I don't know what do you think to the child you know what do you think if mummy had some sessions or if mummy had a space or she had someone to talk to where she could take some of her feelings as well as you have somewhere where you can share yours and so often the kids would be like they're doing this really big nod like not because they and it was it never ever felt like it was because you're pleased you know but but and in a really light actually they were aware that you know a parent needs that support too and i think actually our kids i often say you know kids don't do what we say they do what we do and they internalize how we take care of ourselves they internalize so whilst we're in the moment with our kids especially young kids they are needy they are demanding they
“妈妈，过来看看这个，或者过来和我一起做这个。”有时候说“好的”真的很好，而不是说“给我一分钟”或者“现在不行，五分钟，妈妈要工作，或者我必须做这个，所以我必须完成X、Y和Z”。当你有一个幼儿时，这非常困难，因为你可能正在给他们换尿布，你可能需要完成那项工作。但有时如果安全的话，说“好的，宝贝，现在给我看看，我现在有时间陪你了”真的很好。是的，我认为这就是作为父母，你越能
do need a lot of attention and it is you know hard but equally they're learning from us all the time that if we're never giving to ourselves or we're never kind of holding that boundary and saying I will be with you in a minute I'm just going to have a glass of water because I'm thirsty we're teaching them so much about not just their needs matter now but their needs matter when they're older that their needs matter because we're modeling it and that can feel hard sometimes but actually we can't pour out what we don't pour in. Yeah, really strong point. And I know from when we've spoken before, you said sometimes it's really nice to as soon as your child says to you,
意识到你的能量槽在哪里，并进行这种持续的检查。所以我有一个非常简单的方法，我会问自己，并让我的客户一直问自己：“我感觉如何？我需要什么？”你越能进行这种练习，比如当你早上醒来时，这不需要超过10秒钟，当你上厕所时，当你洗澡时，只需暂停并慢下来。如果你总是处于匆忙之中，你就无法对自己产生同情心，你就无法调节自己。现代的育儿方式，现代的生活方式，如果你问任何人：“你最近怎么样？”大多数人的回答要么是“我很好”，要么是“我很好，我只是太忙了，对吧？”或者“我只是在应付所有的事情。”因为我们确实如此，因为现代生活方式就是我们要做所有的事情。我必须每天大声对自己说：
Mummy, come and look at this or come and do this with me. Sometimes it's really nice to say, OK, rather than going, give me a minute or, you know, not now, five minutes, mummy's got to work or I've got to do this so I've got to finish you know doing x y and z it's really difficult when you've got a young child because you might be in the middle of changing their nappy and it was you're gonna you know you probably need to finish that job but sometimes it's really nice if it's safe to do so to say okay lovely show me now I've got time for you now yeah and I think that's where the more we can be as a parent the more you can become
“Jade，暂停，慢下来。”一直这样，因为我匆忙。我从一件事匆忙赶到另一件事。我希望我的孩子们看到我这样做。我希望我的孩子们看到我只是暂停并深呼吸，而不是告诉我的孩子们：“慢下来，暂停，呼吸。”我做到了。这就是那种共同暂停并深呼吸的力量。而不是告诉我们的孩子冷静下来，我们必须成为那个以身作则、展示它并在他们面前做到的人。所以我想，是的，如果我们总是处于匆忙之中，如果我们总是整天忙于应付所有的事情，要做到这一点真的很难。所以我邀请人们思考，如果他们觉得自己的神经系统着火了，如果他们觉得不知所措，觉得被掏空了，那不是因为你坏或有任何缺陷。这是因为
aware of where your tanks are and kind of do this continual check-in so i have this really simple thing where i will ask myself and get my clients to ask themselves all the time what do i feel what do i need and the more you can have that practice you know when you wake up in the morning it doesn't have to take more than 10 seconds whilst you're on on the loo, whilst you're in the shower, just pause and slow down. You cannot be compassionate towards yourself. You cannot regulate yourself if we are always in a rush. And the modern way of parenting, the modern way of life, if you speak to anybody, how are you doing? Mostly the response will either be, I'm fine, or it will be, I'm fine, I'm just so busy, right? Or I'm just juggling all the things. Because we are, because the modern way of life is we're doing all the things. And I have to say out loud to myself on a daily occurrence,
你的神经系统着火了，被拉伸了。所以我们如何慢下来、暂停、呼吸并做一些非常基础的事情？但实际上，有时我们甚至没有意识到我们正在经历这一天，我们屏住呼吸，我们把自己绷得很紧，直到我们停下来问自己：“我感觉如何？我需要什么？”并只需暂停，给自己许可去暂停。非常有力的建议。确实如此。只需重新调整自己，重新扎根自己。所以很明显，作为父母大吼大叫，甚至当他们长大一点后，这种吼叫得到回应，这是一个大问题。这不会让我们任何人感觉良好
Jade, pause, slow down all the time because I rush. I rush from thing to thing. And I want my kids to see me do that. I want my kids see me kind of just pause and take a breath instead of telling my kids, slow down, pause, breathe. I do it. And that's the power of that kind of co pause and take a breath. Instead of telling my kids, slow down, pause, breathe, I do it. And that's the power of that kind of co-regulation piece. Instead of telling our kids to calm down, we have to be the person to kind of model it, show it and do it in front of them. And so I guess, yeah, it's really hard to do that if we are always in a rush, if we are always spinning all of the plates all of the time. So I guess I invite people to think that if they are feeling like their nervous system is lit on fire, if they are feeling like they are overwhelmed, that they are stretched thin, it's not because you're bad or faulty in any way. It's because
作为父母。你知道，在前三四次要求某人做某事时，我相当冷静。我想从我们所说的内容中，我的学习点是：少忙一点，不要仅仅期望我可以从另一个房间要求完成某事。走到孩子身边，轻轻地把手放在他们身上，说：“来吧，宝贝，是时候穿上鞋子了。我们需要现在做这件事。”而不是仅仅调大音量，这是我从今天学到的第一点。作为父母，即使在第五次不得不要求某人做某事时，我们如何能少吼叫？所以，是的，太棒了。这是一个很好的问题。也是我一直被问到的问题。所以首先要说的是，在我家里，尽管人们会说：
your nervous system is lit on fire, stretched. And so how can we slow down and pause and breathe and do some of that really basic stuff, but actually that we just, sometimes we don't even realize we're going through our day and we're holding our breath and we're holding ourselves tight and we don't realise until we stop and ask ourselves, what do I feel? What do I need? And just pause, give yourself permission to just pause. Such powerful advice. It really is. And just re-centre yourself, just re-ground yourself. So obviously shouting as a parent, and then even as they get a bit older, having that shouting reciprocated, that is a big one. It doesn't make any of us feel good
“去见Jade，去和Jade谈谈。她是冷静育儿教练。”对于听众来说，理解我并非时刻保持冷静，我家也会发生吼叫，这一点非常重要。我在一个非常有爱的家庭中长大，我非常幸运拥有一个非常有爱的家庭，但也是一个非常、非常吵闹、爱吼叫的家庭。所以这已经成为我人生工作的一部分。所以这是我仍然在努力的事情。我不认为神经系统调节和所有这些情绪调节、治愈我们的育儿触发点——我们可以整天谈论这些——是一劳永逸的事情。因为我们生活的方式，你总会遇到这些问题，对吧？所以这是
as a parent. You know, I'm quite calm for the first three or four times of asking someone to do something. I think already from tuning into what we've been saying, I think me to be a bit less busy and not just expect that I can request something to be done from another room is my learning point, really. Go to the child, gently put your hands on them and come on, baby, it's time to get your shoes on. We need to do that now rather than just cranking up the volume is my first learning point from today. How can we clout less as parents, even on the fifth time of having to ask someone to do something? So yeah, great. That's a great question. And one I'm asked all the time. So the first thing to say is that in my house, even though people will say,
第一点，这是我们必须有意识地去努力的事情。关于要求三四次，我会说：要求一次，也许两次，了解你的极限。但我绝不会要求超过两次。如果我们不得不要求第三次，是的，我们开始感到有力量了。我们开始改变我们沟通的方式，而不是期望我们的孩子改变。这样你被触发的次数会少得多。所以，就像你说的，走到房间里，蹲下来和他们平视。我知道感觉像是在重复可能会让人沮丧，但这就是帮助孩子的天性，因为我们是在与不成熟的大脑打交道。我每天提醒自己，我的另一个口头禅是：“25年，Jade，大脑完全发育需要25年。”你知道，我想
you know, you know, go see Jay, go speak to Jay. She's the calm parenting, you know, coach. It's really important for me that listeners, that people understand that I am not calm all of the time and shouting does happen in my house. I grew up in a very loving home. I was very fortunate to have a very loving home, but a very, very loud shouty home. And so it has become, I guess, kind of some of my life's work. And so it is stuff that I still work on on I don't think nervous system regulation and all this emotion regulation healing our parenting triggers that we can talk about all day long is a one and done thing you're going to come up against because of the way we live our lives right so that's the
真的，能够……所以对我来说，其中一件事是吼叫。虽然我们不喜欢它，没人喜欢被吼，人们也不喜欢吼叫，但这实际上是我们做的一件事，因为它确实调节了我们。在我们的迷走神经上，让我们回到一种扎根的存在状态，它连接着你的声带。这是一种表达，就像是，它把我们需要从身体里排出的东西排出来。所以我们必须找到其他方法来做到这一点。仅仅试图停止吼叫就像告诉孩子停止打人一样。就像是：“好吧，那股能量要去哪里？”我们必须为我们的能量找到一个出口。如果我感到吼叫即将来临，对我来说真正有帮助的一件事是，我必须把自己带走。我必须深呼吸，把背靠在墙上，把脚踩在地上。
first thing is it is something that we do have to work on consciously in terms of asking three or four times what I would say there is that ask once maybe twice know your limit but I would say there is that ask once, maybe twice, know your limit, but I would never ask more than twice. If we're having to ask a third time, yeah, we get to feel empowered. We get to change the way that we then communicate instead of expecting our kids to change. And you're going to get much less triggered then. And so it is a case of, like you said, going to the room, getting down on their level. And I know it can be frustrating feeling like we're on repeat but that that is the nature of of helping kids because we're working with immature brains we're working with you know reminding I remind myself daily another mantra of mine is 25 years Jade it takes 25 years for the brain to be fully developed you know and I guess
有很多事情我可以做。在我家里，真正帮助我的一件事是我唱歌。因为对我来说，它仍然在使用我的声带。它仍然在排出一些东西。我不是歌手。我五音不全。但无论如何，它可能会像这样：“这变得非常紧张。”
really it's being able to so for me one of the things is shouting whilst we don't enjoy it nobody likes being shouted at people don't like shouting it is actually a thing that we do because it does regulate us so on our vagus nerve that brings us back into a grounded state of being is attached to your vocal cords it's an it's an expression of like you know it's getting something out of our bodies that needs to come out of our bodies. So we do have to find other ways that we can do that. Just to try to stop shouting is like telling a child to stop hitting. It's like, well, where's that energy going to go? We've got to find an outlet for our energy. One of the things that really helps me if I get to a point where I'm feeling like the shout is coming, I do have to take myself off. I do have to kind of breathe, push my back against the wall, push my feet into the ground.
对我来说，它阻止了这种巨大的吼叫从我身上出来。孩子们往往会笑，这往往会平息事情。它并不每次都奏效，但这只是一个例子。但这是在思考，而不是思考“我如何停止吼叫”——就像对待孩子的任何行为一样，而不是思考“我如何停止那种行为”，深入行为之下，思考“我感觉如何？我需要什么？”因为当你理解了冰山之下是什么——冰山一角是吼叫，但表面之下有很多东西在发生。当我们能够获得我们未满足的需求并找到满足这些需求的方法时，你最终会减少吼叫。但这确实需要练习。这太有趣了，Jade，我从来没有
There's lots of things I can do. One of the things in my house that really helps me is I sing. Because for me, it's still using my vocal cords. It's still getting something out. And so I'm not a singer. I'm tone deaf. But anyway, it might go along the lines of something like this. It's getting very stressful.
我能做的事情有很多。在家里对我很有帮助的一件事就是唱歌。因为对我来说，这仍然是在使用我的声带，仍然是在释放某种东西。我不是歌手，我五音不全。但不管怎样，它可能听起来像这样。这真的让人压力很大。
And for me, it stops this like huge shout coming out out my kids tend to laugh and it tends to kind of simmer things down it doesn't work every time but that's just one example but it's thinking about instead of thinking how can i stop shouting the same way with any behavior with a child instead of thinking how can i stop that behavior get beneath the behavior and think what do i feel what do i need because when you understand that what is creating what's what's beneath the iceberg is you know the tip of the iceberg is the shout for example but there's just so much that's going on beneath the surface when we can access what our unmet needs are and find ways that we can meet those needs then you're going to end up shouting less but it does take practice that is so interesting jade i've never
对我来说，这能阻止我对着孩子们大吼大叫，他们往往会笑出来，这往往能让事情平息下来。虽然不是每次都奏效，但这只是一个例子。与其思考“我该如何停止吼叫”，不如像对待孩子的任何行为一样，不要只盯着行为本身，而是要深入挖掘行为背后的原因，思考“我的感受是什么？我需要什么？”因为当你理解了冰山之下是什么——比如吼叫只是冰山一角，而水面之下其实隐藏着很多东西——当我们能够意识到自己未被满足的需求，并找到满足这些需求的方法时，你最终会减少吼叫。但这确实需要练习。这太有趣了，杰德，我从来没有
heard that about the singing before but it is something that I tend to do. But I had always thought it was not a great thing. And I sort of realised I would do it and I'd try to be more mindful of it because I thought it was almost like dissociation. But actually, I think that's really empowering knowing that the physical experience of singing might actually help the calming process especially if I if I'm more careful about what I'm singing I think I will often just sing I don't know like a chorus that I've got stuck in my head but if I could actually sing some of the moment it might bring everybody more online so I thank you for that I really love that yeah lots of my clients do end up saying now
以前听说过唱歌这件事，但这确实是我倾向于做的事情。但我一直认为这不是什么好事。我意识到自己会这样做，并试图对此更加留心，因为我觉得这几乎就像是一种解离。但实际上，我认为这非常有力量，因为知道唱歌的身体体验可能真的有助于平静过程，特别是如果我对自己唱的内容更加注意的话。我想我通常只是唱一些我脑子里挥之不去的副歌，但如果我能真正唱出当下的感受，可能会让每个人都更加投入，所以我为此感谢你，我真的很喜欢这一点。是的，我的很多客户最终都会说
that they spend they spend a lot of their time singing but I think it's just that the more aware you are of your body I think we are all of us at times quite dissociated from our body because as I said we tend to be holding our breath we tend to be either stuck in the past worrying about the things that we've done the fact that we shouted at our kids this morning and sent them off to school and now we feel terrible or we're stuck worrying about the future like how am I ever gonna I don't know you know cope with whatever it might be and I think I mean the other thing is that a lot of us will say is like I stay calm I stay calm I stay calm and then I flip and it's usually you know tea time bedtime because we've kind of we've held it together we've held it together especially doing kind of the jobs
他们花了很多时间在唱歌上，但我认为这只是因为你对自己身体的觉察力越强，我们所有人有时都会与自己的身体相当疏离，因为正如我所说，我们往往会屏住呼吸，我们往往要么陷入过去，担心我们所做的事情，比如今天早上对孩子大喊大叫并送他们去上学，现在感到非常糟糕；要么陷入对未来的担忧，比如我该如何应对等等。我认为，另一件事是，我们很多人会说“我保持冷静，我保持冷静，我保持冷静”，然后我就崩溃了，这通常是在喝茶时间或睡觉时间，因为我们一直强撑着，特别是在做我们那种工作的时候
that we do in terms of we pour a lot of ourselves out as psychologists we're giving to others we're working with trauma and we end up coming home our window of tolerance has been shrunk and we have to continually as a parent like our capacity as a parent once you are a parent is is much lower you know because you can your kids are going to push or prod you and ask for things and you know meltdowns tantrums like it all of these things load your load nervous system. So they shrink your window of tolerance. So we have to be thinking, actually, what can I build into my day? Instead of just getting through my day and then think, oh, my child's now kicking off. I now need to regulate. We need to be regulating all day long. We need to be getting up and moving and having a break and sipping water and taking some breaths,
作为心理学家，我们倾注了很多心血，我们在给予他人，我们在处理创伤，最终回到家时，我们的容纳之窗已经缩小了。作为父母，一旦你成为父母，你的能力就会降低很多，因为你的孩子会推搡你、催促你，要求你做这做那，还有崩溃、发脾气，所有这些事情都会给你的神经系统增加负担。所以它们缩小了你的容纳之窗。因此，我们必须思考：实际上，我可以在我的一天中建立什么？而不是仅仅熬过这一天，然后想“哦，我的孩子现在开始闹了，我现在需要调节”。我们需要整天都在进行调节。我们需要站起来走动，休息一下，喝口水，做几次深呼吸，
telling ourselves to slow down, all this stuff throughout our day. How can we weave this into our day instead of expecting ourselves to kind of stay this idea of staying calm? Really what we're doing is we're just holding something very tightly and then the lid flips. So it's kind of reframing how we regulate ourselves throughout the day and not just during those moments of chaos. Such wise words again. And even yesterday, I was on my way back from a very high energy, high intensity gym class called Blaze. And I was, you know, physically tired and spent, but mentally energized and thinking, oh, I know I'm going to be going home in a calmer state than that which I left the house, you know, having just cooked dinner and then kind of got changed and run out the house. I knew that I
告诉自己慢下来，所有这些事情都要贯穿我们的一天。我们如何将这些融入我们的一天，而不是期望自己保持那种“保持冷静”的状态？实际上，我们所做的只是紧紧抓住某些东西，然后盖子就掀开了。所以，这实际上是重新构建我们如何在一天中调节自己，而不仅仅是在那些混乱的时刻。又是如此睿智的话语。即使是昨天，我在从一个名为“Blaze”的高能量、高强度的健身课回来的路上。我身体上很累，精疲力竭，但精神上却很振奋，心想：“哦，我知道我回家时的状态会比我离开家时更平静。”你知道，刚做完晚饭，换了衣服就跑出家门。我知道我
would have more capacity for whatever was about to unfold at bedtime. And for me, it's only really in the last four years, I would say that exercise has really become very integral to me I kind of wish I'd had that realization earlier in my life but maybe someone watching this or listening to this hasn't yet discovered the thing that's going to really help them to manage everything in their life better you know not just parenting I think it's that finding that thing isn't it and for some I think movement is key because movement does regulate our nervous system. But for some people, it might be running, for some people, it might be the gym or personal training, or some people might be restorative yoga or just getting out for walks. I always say to parents, if in doubt, if you feel like your child's
对于睡前即将发生的一切会有更多的能力去应对。对我来说，直到最近四年，我才可以说运动对我来说已经变得非常不可或缺。我有点希望我生命中早点有这种认识，但也许正在观看或收听的人还没有发现能真正帮助他们更好地管理生活中一切的事情，你知道，不仅仅是育儿。我认为这就是找到那个东西，不是吗？对一些人来说，我认为运动是关键，因为运动确实能调节我们的神经系统。但对有些人来说，可能是跑步，对有些人来说，可能是健身房或私人教练，或者有些人可能是修复瑜伽或只是出去散步。我总是对父母说，如果有疑问，如果你觉得你的孩子
feeling kind of, you know, on edge and you're feeling on edge, get outside. If anything, just get outside. Again, that has lots of restorative kind of you know ways of being outside and being in nature that there's no one way of doing it that's in some ways the lovely thing and can be hard when you've got more than one child because you might find that one child you know in terms of their sensory system they need you know they need to be climbing walls and you know jumping on trampolines and that really kind of like restores them and then you may have another child who actually needs to do drawing and puzzles and so having these kind of different needs within a family system can be really challenging or if you have a child who is really high energy and you're kind
感觉有点紧张，而你也感到紧张，那就去户外。如果什么都做不了，至少去户外。同样，在户外和置身于大自然中有很多恢复性的方式，没有一种单一的方法，这在某种程度上是可爱之处，但当你有一个以上的孩子时可能会很困难，因为你可能会发现一个孩子在感官系统方面，他们需要爬墙、在蹦床上跳跃，这真的能让他们恢复，然后你可能有另一个孩子，实际上需要画画和拼图，所以在一个家庭系统中拥有这些不同的需求可能真的很有挑战性，或者如果你有一个精力非常充沛的孩子，而你又
of like trying to down regulate yourself from that that can be really hard and parents will often ask me you know well how do I regulate myself when I don't have any space from my kids you know they literally will follow me to the loo and and that is hard but I also think therefore parents of young children do have to have these kind of practices where we are doing it with our kids they are there and and that's why I sort of often recommend you know sometimes wearing earbuds you know where you can still hear your kids but it dampens down the noise a little bit can be really helpful you know I definitely have a noise sensitivity which is wild having three kids but like yeah putting it back against the wall reducing stimuli around yourself so that you can just regulate
试图让自己从那种状态中降温，那可能会非常困难。父母经常问我：“当我没有一点个人空间时，我该如何调节自己？”你知道，他们真的会跟着我进厕所，这确实很难。但我同时也认为，幼儿的父母确实必须有这些练习，我们在和孩子一起做这些事，他们就在那里。这就是为什么我经常建议有时戴上耳塞，你仍然可以听到孩子的声音，但它会稍微减弱噪音，这真的很有帮助。你知道，我绝对有噪音敏感度，有三个孩子真是太疯狂了，但把背靠在墙上，减少周围的刺激，这样你就可以稍微调节
yourself a little bit and it's hard but it's it's actually really important for our kids to see us doing that work because as i said they don't kids don't do what we say if you tell your kid to calm down actually think about a time when someone has told you when you're in that enraged you know your brain is enraged and someone says to you just just calm down take a breath you know it actually enrages us so actually instead of in those kind of meltdown moments the best way to respond is to regulate yourself and actually focus more on you than your child obviously keeping your child safe but instead of telling your child to breathe to down. You do the thing you want to see in your child and you'll see that co-regulation happen much sooner. Yeah, and that's just brought back a really special memory actually of when I just had one child and doing things like bathing him every day
一下自己。这很难，但实际上对我们的孩子来说，看到我们做这些工作非常重要，因为正如我所说，孩子们不会做我们说的事。如果你告诉你的孩子冷静下来，实际上想想当有人在你愤怒时——你知道你的大脑很愤怒——有人对你说“冷静点，深呼吸”，这实际上会让我们更愤怒。所以，在那些崩溃的时刻，最好的回应方式是调节你自己，实际上更多地关注你自己而不是你的孩子，当然要保证孩子的安全，但不要告诉你的孩子去呼吸。你要做你想在孩子身上看到的事情，你会看到共调节发生得更快。是的，这确实勾起了一个非常特别的回忆，实际上是我刚有一个孩子的时候，每天给他洗澡
like in the evenings when he was kind of a toddler. That went right out the window when the next one came along. But he was tired. It was getting to the end of the day. Sometimes bath times would be a little bit more difficult. And I, you know, I was the gentlest of gentle parents when I just had one. And I remember him vexing me a bit at bath time. And he must have spotted me do things like time and time again. Suddenly he went, and I thought, oh, yeah, I do do that. Because I really didn't want him to have the experience of being shouted at. So when I noticed I was going to shout or wanted to shout, losing my temper I would and just take a moment and he began
就像他还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时，在晚上那样。当第二个孩子出生时，这一切就完全抛到脑后了。但他累了，快到一天结束的时候了。有时洗澡时间会稍微困难一些。而且，你知道，当我只有一个孩子时，我是最温柔的父母。我记得他在洗澡时让我有点烦恼。他一定发现我一次又一次地做那些事。突然他去了，我想，哦，是的，我确实那样做了。因为我真的不想让他有被大声呵斥的经历。所以当我注意到我要大喊大叫或想大喊大叫、失去耐心时，我会停下来，花点时间，他开始
to do that and that's you know exactly exactly what you said isn't it yeah absolutely I remember a time watching one of my kids kind of with another child who was getting really upset and and she was you know only I think like four at the time, my daughter, and she was doing it with this other child. They had this kind of breathing ball that I have. And she was always teaching this three-year-old like how to use it. And it was lovely. And there was one bit where they wanted to sort of run into the playroom
那样做，这就是你说的完全正确，不是吗？是的，绝对是。我记得有一次看着我的一个孩子和另一个变得非常不安的孩子在一起，当时我的女儿只有四岁，她正在和那个孩子一起做这件事。他们有一个我有的那种呼吸球。她一直在教这个三岁的孩子如何使用它。这很可爱。有一点他们想跑进游戏室
because I saw it happening and just start doing a crazy dance and cheering and letting off. And I thought, no, just let it be. Just let it be. It's happening and it's lovely. But also there's a time, you know, when you go let it be, just let it be. It's happening. And it's lovely. But also there's a time, you know, when you go from one to two, it's a big transition, right? And I can say going from two to three is another big transition. My youngest is nine months now. And there was a time, and it was a very popular social media post because I was very, very honest. I had to get asleep. So, you know, I was incredibly tired. I can't remember
因为我看到它发生了，就开始跳疯狂的舞蹈，欢呼和释放。我想，不，就让它顺其自然吧。就让它顺其自然吧。它正在发生，这很可爱。但也有时候，你知道，当你从一个孩子变成两个孩子时，这是一个巨大的转变，对吧？我可以肯定地说，从两个变成三个是另一个巨大的转变。我最小的孩子现在九个月大了。有一次，这是一个非常受欢迎的社交媒体帖子，因为我非常非常诚实。我必须睡觉。所以，你知道，我非常累。我不记得
right now the semantics, but I just remember in front of my other two children having the baby and shouting, shut up. It was not a fine moment. And actually my child saying, don't say that to him. He's a baby, which she's right. But it's what I did next that really mattered which was just like I gave myself a moment to pause and acknowledge this is hard internally this is hard I'm a good parent having a hard time so I repaired internally with myself which then enabled me to say this is a lot baby down and apologize to the baby and say do you know what you're absolutely right mummy needs to go calm herself down. Shouting's not okay.
现在具体的细节，但我只记得在我的另外两个孩子面前，抱着婴儿大喊“闭嘴”。那不是一个美好的时刻。实际上我的孩子说：“不要那样对他。他是个婴儿。”她是对的。但接下来我所做的事情才真正重要，那就是我给了自己一个暂停的时刻，并在内心承认：这很难，这很难，我是一个正在经历困难的好父母。所以我自己在内心进行了修复，这使我能够说：“这太多了，宝宝放下。”并向宝宝道歉，说：“你知道吗，你是完全正确的，妈妈需要去冷静一下。大喊大叫是不对的。”
And so one of the things, if a parent can get good at anything, it's repair. Because we are teaching our kids how to mess up, how to be human, how to be imperfect, and how to take responsibility and to say sorry. But the bit that's often missing when we repair with our kids is that first initial bit, which is to repair with yourself I am a good mom having a hard time and not a bad mom doing bad things because if we don't do that piece the shame builds up and then it's really hard to apologize when we're feeling shameful it's really hard to take responsibility and you're more likely to shout again the next time because again it's it's layering the pressure that we put on ourselves yeah so i try and talk really openly and honestly about that because i never ever want to think that
所以，如果父母能擅长任何事情，那就是修复。因为我们正在教我们的孩子如何犯错，如何成为人类，如何变得不完美，以及如何承担责任和道歉。但我们在与孩子修复关系时经常缺失的那一部分，是最初的那一部分，即与你自己修复：我是一个正在经历困难的好妈妈，而不是一个做坏事的坏妈妈。因为如果我们不这样做，羞耻感就会积累起来，那么当我们感到羞耻时，道歉就真的很难了，承担责任就真的很难了，而且你下次更有可能再次大喊大叫，因为这又是在给我们自己施加压力。是的，所以我尽量非常公开和诚实地谈论这一点，因为我永远不想认为
anybody thinks that there's any psychologist or parenting coach out there doing this parenting gig perfectly there's no such thing and i don't actually believe it would be helpful to our kids if we were personally yeah and you know i was moved by that story um both when when you told me it for the first time, but also now, like really hard. And when you've got someone screaming in your face that doesn't seem to want to stop or respond to normal things you've tried, it's making no difference. And it's very loud. You know, they use baby screaming as a torture, don't they, for prisoners and kind of SAS practice. Because it's supposed to be a frequency that we find very uncomfortable because it's supposed to move us to take action, to work out whatever it is that's causing our baby distress.
任何人认为有任何心理学家或育儿教练在完美地完成育儿这项工作。根本没有这回事，而且我实际上不认为如果我们是完美的，这对我们的孩子会有帮助。是的，你知道，我被那个故事感动了，嗯，无论是在你第一次告诉我的时候，还是现在，真的很难。当你有一个人在你面前尖叫，似乎不想停止或对你尝试的正常事情做出反应时，这没有任何区别。而且声音非常大。你知道，他们用婴儿的尖叫声作为一种折磨，不是吗？对囚犯和SAS训练来说。因为它应该是一种我们觉得非常不舒服的频率，因为它应该促使我们采取行动，找出导致我们宝宝痛苦的原因。
But obviously, if we've tried all those things, it's really hard. Yeah, it's really hard. And I think, again, why I use this language, like it activates a part of us. It was a part of me that was distressed, overstimulated. I was dysregulated. It's not all of me. I don't take it on as an identity. It's this part of me was just, woof, and I just blew and then I repaired.
但显然，如果我们尝试了所有这些事情，这真的很难。是的，这真的很难。而且我认为，再次说明我为什么使用这种语言，它激活了我们的一部分。那是我的一个感到痛苦、过度刺激的部分。我失调了。这并不代表全部的我。我不会把它当作一种身份。只是我的这一部分，呼，我爆发了，然后我修复了。
And then again, going back to that, what do I feel? What do I need? And sometimes we can't always meet those needs. Because if I'm brutally honest, what I've needed more of this year is sleep. But I have a normal baby, very active, not a fan of sleep. Don't know why I thought third time around might be different. But sometimes just acknowledging, having that acknowledge that there's an unmet need there can be enough in itself. Acknowledging I'm finding this hard because it is hard, not because I'm failing or doing it wrong in some way. The stories we tell ourselves matter. And I think therefore being part of, whether it's through a friend or a friendship group or some kind of way that you can connect with other people that you feel you can be your true self with and I think that could be hard in today's even though like in some ways you can be on social media and have you know 30,000 people follow you like it doesn't necessarily mean you're connected to people or you can you know you can have all these friends but I think you know as parents we really have to have like that connection with someone or a couple of people
然后再次回到那个问题，我感觉到了什么？我需要什么？有时我们不能总是满足这些需求。因为如果我坦诚地说，我今年最需要的是睡眠。但我有一个正常的宝宝，非常活跃，不喜欢睡觉。不知道为什么我以为第三次可能会有所不同。但有时仅仅是承认，承认那里有一个未满足的需求本身就足够了。承认我发现这很难，因为这确实很难，而不是因为我失败了或以某种方式做错了。我们告诉自己的故事很重要。因此，我认为成为其中的一部分，无论是通过朋友还是朋友圈，或者某种你可以与他人联系的方式，让你觉得可以做真实的自己，我认为这在今天可能很难，即使在某些方面你可以在社交媒体上拥有3万名粉丝，但这并不一定意味着你与人有联系，或者你可以拥有所有这些朋友，但我认为，你知道，作为父母，我们真的必须拥有那种与某个人或几个人
that you feel you can be your true self with that you're not going to be judged and and that in itself is very regulating to give us that permission to feel and I always say you know when you're helping yourself or helping your kids we can only regulate a feeling that you give yourself permission to have if we are telling ourselves I shouldn't feel that feeling is going to grow that feeling is going to get hard and you end up actually the problem is not the feeling itself so if you're feeling anxious for example about something anxiety is never really the issue it's how you feel about the feeling right you feel anxious about being anxious and not being able to cope with those feelings and so we really have to expand our tolerance so that we can help our kids do the same and I think that's I personally think that some of the hardest parts
的联系，让你觉得可以做真实的自己，你不会被评判，这本身就是非常具有调节作用的，给予我们感受的许可。我总是说，当你帮助自己或帮助你的孩子时，我们只能调节你允许自己拥有的那种感觉。如果我们告诉自己“我不应该有那种感觉”，那种感觉就会增长，那种感觉就会变得困难，你最终会发现问题本身并不是感觉。所以如果你对某事感到焦虑，焦虑从来都不是真正的问题，而是你对这种感觉的感受，对吧？你对感到焦虑感到焦虑，并且无法应对这些感觉，所以我们真的必须扩大我们的容纳能力，这样我们才能帮助我们的孩子做同样的事情。我认为这是，我个人认为这是最困难的部分之一
of parenting is actually the sort of reparenting of ourselves, that regulating ourselves and allowing ourselves to feel what we feel, because that is how we're going to help our kids to do that. Oh, Jade, you know, everything you say, you know, and it's just really nice that even you say I don't get it right every time. And I think for me, it's knowing that I'm a good enough parent and that's okay. You know, we don't need to be amazing parent. We don't need to be the best parent. You know, you don't need to literally be nominated for mum of the year and get an award from Carol Vorderman. Like, we're all parents of the year. Like, you know, at some points of the day, the week, the year, the month, you know, it's just that we haven't been nominated. Maybe we should nominate ourselves. But we're just, it's okay to be good enough parenting is more than okay because we're not teaching our kids how to be perfect I mean how would they live up to that right if we want
育儿实际上是我们自己的再育儿，即调节我们自己并允许自己感受我们的感受，因为这就是我们将如何帮助我们的孩子做到这一点。哦，Jade，你知道，你说的每一件事，而且很高兴即使是你也说“我并没有每次都做对”。我认为对我来说，知道我是一个足够好的父母，这就足够了。你知道，我们不需要成为令人惊叹的父母。我们不需要成为最好的父母。你知道，你不需要真的被提名为年度母亲并从Carol Vorderman那里获得奖项。就像，我们都是年度父母。就像，你知道，在一天、一周、一年、一个月中的某些时刻，你知道，只是我们没有被提名。也许我们应该提名自己。但我们只是，成为足够好的父母是可以的，这不仅仅是可以，因为我们不是在教我们的孩子如何变得完美。我的意思是，如果我们要
our kids to be more kinder to themselves we have to be kinder to ourselves if we want our kids to learn the idea of like growing up like sometimes we do want our kids to kind of be in a certain way it would make our life easier if they kind of you know followed our every word they said yes mom no mom to everything that you know we did and you know that we don't want our kids to become adults who follow authority blindly who never stand up for themselves who never assert themselves and say no that doesn't feel good so that can make parenting challenging but knowing that if we want our kids to respond to mistakes they can make mistakes in life like we all do and I love this idea it really helps me in business actually the idea
我们的孩子变得更善待自己，我们就必须善待自己。如果我们想让我们的孩子学习成长的概念，有时我们确实希望我们的孩子以某种方式行事，如果他们遵循我们的每一句话，对我们所做的一切说“是的妈妈，不妈妈”，那会让我们的生活更轻松。而且你知道，我们不希望我们的孩子成为盲目服从权威、从不为自己挺身而出、从不主张自己并说“不，那感觉不好”的成年人。所以这会让育儿变得具有挑战性，但知道如果我们想让我们的孩子对错误做出反应，他们可以在生活中犯错，就像我们所有人一样。我喜欢这个想法，它实际上在商业上对我很有帮助，这个想法
that fail is first attempt in learning you either get the outcome you wanted or the lesson you needed and if we want to raise kids who can kind of be resilient and you know stuff's going to be thrown their way that is going to upset them hurt them the first heartache you know and so we want to help them yeah feel that they can cope with that you know and so actually part of the discord we have with our kids and the disagreements and the arguments or the sibling rivalry it's all part of life and yeah i think it's it's the good enough is good enough and also if we can work at not taking our children's behavior personally which is hard it changes the way you you know when you change the way you, you know, when you change
即“失败是学习的第一次尝试”。你要么得到你想要的结果，要么得到你需要的教训。如果我们想培养能够适应逆境的孩子，你知道，事情会向他们袭来，这会让他们心烦意乱、伤害他们，第一次心碎，你知道，所以我们想帮助他们，是的，感觉到他们可以应对。所以实际上，我们与孩子之间的不和谐、分歧、争吵或兄弟姐妹之间的竞争，都是生活的一部分。是的，我认为“足够好就是足够好”。而且，如果我们能努力不把孩子的行为个人化，这很难，它会改变你，你知道，当你改变你，你知道，当你改变
the way you look at something, the thing you look at changes, right? So if we can change our perception that our kids are not giving us a hard time, they're having a hard time and we can be in that with them, it's messy and that's okay. That's part of life. Yes, indeed it is. And I'm just hearing, as you say, just in case we haven't really covered this aspect already, and I know it's a big topic to kind of cram into a couple of minutes, but some parents might be watching this and thinking, well, this doesn't really apply to my child. Perhaps they've got an autism diagnosis or are heading towards one, or perhaps maybe even selective mute or ADHD diagnosis is pending or due. How do we begin to kind of apply some of this trying to shout less
你看待事物的方式，你所看的事物就会改变，对吧？所以如果我们能改变我们的看法，即我们的孩子不是在给我们制造麻烦，而是他们正在经历困难，我们可以和他们一起经历这些，这很混乱，但这没关系。这是生活的一部分。是的，确实如此。我刚才听到，正如你所说，以防我们还没有真正涵盖这个方面，我知道这是一个很难在几分钟内塞进去的大话题，但一些父母可能正在观看这个节目，心想：“好吧，这并不真正适用于我的孩子。”也许他们有自闭症诊断或正朝着这个方向发展，或者也许甚至有选择性缄默症或多动症诊断正在等待或即将到来。我们如何开始应用这种尝试少大喊大叫
to children if it feels like our children are not as typical as some of the examples we've used? I mean, I think the first thing is that regardless of what's going on really is that being able to ask for some kind of support and whether that's paid support if that's possible you know in terms of kind of because there's a lot at the moment with you know people on long waiting lists or waiting for an assessment and if you can get support because ultimately regardless when kids do have greater needs it's harder but equally we start to question like well I've tried some of these like traditional strategies so for example with highly sensitive, well, I've tried some of these like traditional strategies. So for example, with highly sensitive, deeply feeling kids, I've tried to validate their feelings, it doesn't work, or it seems to explode them, then the first thing is, use the observation
对孩子，如果感觉我们的孩子不像我们使用的一些例子那样典型？我的意思是，我认为第一件事是，无论发生了什么，能够寻求某种支持，无论是付费支持（如果可能的话），因为目前有很多关于人们在漫长的等待名单上或等待评估的情况。如果你能得到支持，因为最终无论孩子是否有更大的需求，这都更难，但同样我们开始质疑，比如“我已经尝试了一些这些传统的策略，例如对于高度敏感、深情的孩子，我已经尝试验证他们的感受，它不起作用，或者它似乎让他们爆炸了”，那么第一件事是，利用你所做的观察
that you're making and know that okay, this isn't working, not because I'm doing it wrong, something isn't working. And that may be a time when to access support, whether that's through a community of other parents or a professional or what that might look like can be different for different people. And yeah, like we said right at the beginning, like trying to parent on our own, it just, you know, even for myself, like trying to work out certain things with my own kids, like it's really helpful when I can have a conversation with somebody else that can kind of help me stand back from my own kids and my own situation. Why do coaches have coaches?
并知道“好吧，这不起作用，不是因为我做错了，而是有什么东西不起作用”。这可能是一个寻求支持的时候，无论是通过其他父母的社区还是专业人士，或者那看起来可能对不同的人来说是不同的。是的，就像我们在最开始说的那样，试图独自育儿，它只是，你知道，即使对我自己来说，试图弄清楚我自己孩子的一些事情，当我能和别人进行对话时，这真的很有帮助，这可以帮助我从我自己的孩子和我自己的情况中退后一步。为什么教练会有教练？
Why do therapists have therapists? For that very reason, you know, to help ourselves with our own stuff we having somebody else that could help us get outside of it is so important so i think seeking out that support as much as possible and just knowing that if you watch something or read something or listen to something and it doesn't resonate with you we think that doesn't work for my kid then take that as as truth like that's okay that doesn't, and it's seeking out more specific kind of knowledge and experience. You know, an example would be for a deeply feeling kid. I often, and this is one tiny tweak, I often recommend instead of validating the feeling,
为什么治疗师会有治疗师？正是因为这个原因，你知道，为了帮助我们处理我们自己的事情，拥有一个可以帮助我们跳出局外的人是如此重要。所以我认为尽可能多地寻求那种支持，并且只要知道如果你观看、阅读或收听了某些东西，而它没有引起你的共鸣，我们认为“那对我的孩子不起作用”，那么就把那当作事实，没关系，那并不意味着什么，而是寻求更具体的知识和经验。你知道，一个例子是对于一个深情的孩子。我经常，这是一个微小的调整，我经常建议不要验证感觉，
I suggest validating the magnitude of the feeling. Because actually for deeply feeling kids, they really want us to know how big it is. And if we're trying to say to those kids, it's not that big, or it's, you know, oh, you're feeling anxious and it just gets bigger. They want us to know how big it is and if we're trying to say to those kids it's not that big or it's you know oh you're feeling anxious and it just gets bigger they want us to know how big it is and so then when we when we say you know is it is that feeling as big as the house or is it as big as the street like it is likely to tell you it's bigger than the street it's as big as the universe and that's the kind of validation piece that they need but it's testing and trying and observing and just learning allowing ourselves to learn we don't like have to know this stuff but we may need support to help us understand
我建议验证感觉的程度。因为实际上对于深情的孩子，他们真的希望我们知道它有多大。如果我们试图对那些孩子说“它没那么大”，或者“哦，你感到焦虑”，它只会变得更大。他们希望我们知道它有多大，如果我们试图对那些孩子说“它没那么大”，或者“哦，你感到焦虑”，它只会变得更大。他们希望我们知道它有多大，所以当我们说“你知道，那种感觉像房子那么大，还是像街道那么大？”它很可能会告诉你它比街道还大，它像宇宙那么大，这就是他们需要的验证部分。但这需要测试、尝试、观察，并只是学习，允许自己学习。我们不需要知道这些东西，但我们可能需要支持来帮助我们理解。
absolutely we may and that is okay jade where can people learn more about you and what you offer if they're like yes i need this dr jade in my life so the main places are I have my website you know www.drjaderedfern.co.uk but also I have my Instagram account where I share all sorts of kind of parenting tips particularly around kind of emotion regulation for kids emotion regulation for parents I guess my kind of niche area is kind of helping not just with the kid but also what's coming up for you and so I often liken this to this idea of with parenting from the inside out because that is going to be the most effective way of how you're going to help your kid. So I have my Instagram, which is at DrJadeRedfern. Yeah, I also run a free parenting community called The Conscious Parent Group, which any parent or parent to be
绝对，我们可能需要，这没关系。Jade，如果人们觉得“是的，我的生活中需要这位Jade博士”，他们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你提供的服务？所以主要的地方是我的网站，你知道 www.drjaderedfern.co.uk，但我也有我的Instagram账号，我在那里分享各种育儿技巧，特别是关于孩子的调节情绪、父母的调节情绪。我想我的利基领域是帮助不仅是孩子，还有你身上出现的问题。所以我经常把这比作“从内而外育儿”的想法，因为这将是你帮助孩子最有效的方式。所以我有了我的Instagram，是 @DrJadeRedfern。是的，我还经营一个名为“The Conscious Parent Group”的免费育儿社区，任何父母或准父母
is very welcome to join. It's completely free. I share daily tips and ideas in there and that's where people can kind of mostly find me. You haven't said it, Jade, but I will help you say it because I think it's an incredible resource. You also run a membership, don't you, for parents, but you also have a great free webinar available that people can access. Yes, absolutely. So my membership for parents is called Inside Out Parenting. And we very much focus on kind of developing skills for helping our kids with emotion regulation, you know, their meltdowns, tantrums, kids not listening and how we as parents can show up. But also we very much focus on parents and their own nervous system regulation.
都非常欢迎加入。它是完全免费的。我在那里分享日常技巧和想法，这就是人们可以找到我的地方。你还没有说出来，Jade，但我会帮你说出来，因为我认为这是一个不可思议的资源。你还为父母经营一个会员计划，不是吗？但你也有一个很棒的免费网络研讨会供人们访问。是的，绝对。所以我的父母会员计划叫做“Inside Out Parenting”。我们非常专注于培养帮助孩子调节情绪的技能，你知道，他们的崩溃、发脾气、孩子不听话，以及我们作为父母如何表现。但我们也非常关注父母和他们自己的神经系统调节。
So there's lots of grab and go videos, we have Q&A sessions and all sorts going on there. It's a really supportive place for parents. And yes, in terms of the free webinar that people can, it's an instant download. It's a 25 minute webinar and it talks parents through kids not listening unless I shout. And it gives lots of actionable strategies
所以那里有很多即取即用的视频，我们有问答环节和各种各样的事情。这对父母来说是一个非常支持的地方。是的，关于人们可以访问的免费网络研讨会，它是一个即时下载。这是一个25分钟的网络研讨会，它引导父母了解“孩子不听话，除非我大喊大叫”。它提供了许多可操作的策略
and it's had amazing results for parents. Parents have come back to me saying, this is like wizardry. It really is about those small moments and the way we can just shift the way we communicate, the way we say things and connect with our children in those tough moments, that will enable kind of greater cooperation and a much more peaceful home.
并且它为父母带来了惊人的结果。父母回到我身边说：“这就像魔法一样。”这确实是关于那些微小的时刻，以及我们可以改变我们沟通的方式、我们说话的方式，并在那些艰难的时刻与我们的孩子建立联系，这将使合作更加顺畅，家庭更加和平。
Absolutely. Thank you so much for your time, Jade. It's been absolutely beautiful speaking with you. And I know this episode will resonate with so many different people for such a variety of different reasons. What you do is very important and thank you for doing it. Thank you so much. Thank you for having me. You're more than welcome. Thank you. Thank you so much for our guest today, Dr. Jade. I adore you and that's why I needed to bring you to the podcast so that we can get your work out there
绝对。非常感谢你的时间，Jade。和你交谈真是太美好了。我知道这一集会因为各种不同的原因引起许多不同人的共鸣。你所做的事情非常重要，感谢你所做的一切。非常感谢。谢谢你邀请我。不客气。谢谢。非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾，Jade博士。我崇拜你，这就是为什么我需要把你带到播客上，这样我们就可以把你的工作推广出去
to support more families who need it. You're just, yeah, so de-shaming and so interesting to speak to and I love the way you talk about your work and the examples that you give. Please, if you have found today's episode useful, please do go and follow Jade on her social accounts too. Whilst you're on your social media accounts, please do come and follow me too. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere, but please do like and subscribe. Do drop a comment because it helps this content to reach a wider audience. If you are listening on Spotify or Apple podcasts, please do rate and review. It is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you would like to
去支持更多需要它的家庭。你真是，是的，如此去羞耻化，交谈起来如此有趣，我喜欢你谈论你的工作和你给出的例子。请，如果你觉得今天的节目有用，请一定要去关注Jade的社交账号。当你在社交媒体账号上时，也请一定要来关注我。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent，但请一定要点赞和订阅。请留下评论，因为它有助于这些内容触及更广泛的受众。如果你在Spotify或Apple播客上收听，请一定要评分和评论。这是你能为任何播客做的最友善的事情。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想
come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community, which is my free Facebook group and is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions. Please do so. You'd be so welcome. If you are an aspiring psychologist, and that's why you are engaging with this content, please do also consider the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can access from just £30 a month. psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
加入“Aspiring Psychologist”社区，这是我的免费Facebook群组，也是Marianne的动力和心态会议的独家主页。请一定要这样做。你会非常受欢迎。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，这就是你参与这些内容的原因，请也考虑“Aspiring Psychologist”会员计划，你每月只需30英镑即可访问。心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路，这是与Marianne博士一起的“Aspiring Psychologist”。我的名字是Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容真的很有趣。它让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了对自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。